Nate Burleson NFL Network analyst you
can see him Monday through Friday on NFL
Network's good morning football starting
at 7:00 a.m. Eastern also working for
CBS with their pregame show good to have
you in there Nate thanks for walking a
couple of blocks to come in are you
kidding me I feel like I've made it now
this is you know I'm trying not to fan
out I was acting cool a second ago I was
like yeah what sound like it's normal
but I'm a big fan so I appreciate you
having me Nate walks in and he goes
where am I sitting and I said over here
he thought he was sitting over with the
Dan answer no no years of New York time
you you've earned it here your reaction
to the Cleveland Browns Hugh Jackson is
gonna stay head coach for next year yeah
I'm not surprised that I feel like he
needs more of an opportunity to kind of
put everything in place when you look at
what's happened over the last couple
years there's a lot of guys a lot of
talent that I've left that billing
building you got to give Hugh Jackson a
chance to bring in the talent that he
wants you know they did fire Shashi
Brown correct yeah and that doesn't
surprise me because I was there for that
brief moment before I retired and let me
just name a few guys Travis Benjamin
Willie Snead Taylor Gabriel these are
three talented wide receivers that
somehow just walked out of that building
without the Browns evaluating the talent
and saying you know what maybe these
guys are Ober talented and we should
keep them and figure out a way for them
to work in the system so given the fact
that Sasha Brown is going you can't let
that much talent leave and then not
produce after that and Hugh he'll have
another year to breathe relax and we'll
see what happens with Josh Gordon that
relationship with the young quarterback
it's Cleveland toxic though for a free
agent you know that's that's a tough
question I try not to dog the city but
with what they had in place with what
they were trying to do I feel like there
is some levels of toxicity toxicity is
that a word yeah yeah but they're trying
to fix that you know when I got there I
remember leaving Miami as a free agent
and then going to Cleveland I'm thinking
all right I have to decide between two
teams I'm at the end of my career the
light in the tunnel is bright as ever
okay this is gonna be the way I write
off into
sunset and I thought I don't want to be
in Miami at 33 years old you know I need
to focus on football and not focus on
hanging out and being on the beach so I
was like you know let's go to Cleveland
I'm familiar with being in a gritty
place I'm familiar with being the
underdog I'm familiar with people
talking about us and I expect them us
and help him trying to change a culture
and once I got there I feel like I felt
like it was more difficult than I
thought to change the culture from
within because they didn't have the
right pillars in place you know when
you're trying to draft a young
quarterback by name of Johnny Manziel
whose heart interested in it and you're
looking at him to be the future of your
organization you know things are gonna
crumble from there and I'm not knocking
Johnny but were you there in training
camp in mansions there was I was there
Manziel and I thought to myself okay
with all the research you did with all
the guys that were in place with all the
quarterbacks that you could have moved
and gotten in free agency or on the
track
you're going with Johnny and at that
time johnny was immature I know Johnny
actually has a friend and he's a
different man now but that was just sit
they kept making bad decision after bad
decision and once those decision starts
to weigh on the players it's almost like
you give up in a sense and now the
players they don't believe anymore
could Manziel play Manziel go play he
was one hell of a quarterback no
knowledge in college he listened he was
a hell of a quarterback in college I'll
give you one example of what we were
doing on the field
I remember one play he ran the wrong
play now he bootlegs the wrong direction
and it wasn't something that was
unfamiliar because we've seen it a few
times and what we heard is that he
didn't do much studying on the weekends
you know he was courtside he was hanging
out on on Swans in the middle of pools
partying in Vegas hey listen if you can
do it do it I was I wasn't even mad at
him I just wanted him to come back and
focus but one play he rolls the wrong
direction and he just ad-libs and he
gives me that point like Gary Payton on
the fast-break the Rain Man and I'm like
all right let me let me go deep he hauls
a vault in that is so tight of a spiral
and it's almost like the field went
silent because we didn't expect it and
we all kind of took a breath I said all
right he has some things to learn he
might be a knucklehead to some but his
talent is there huge hands was fast but
all that talent it
doesn't matter if you don't put the work
in and he didn't put the work and I kept
saying if he could take elements pieces
a blueprint a page out of Russell
Wilson's book yeah the way that you go
and attack the football IQ side of
things then you can piece it together
and be a great quarterback but he just
didn't want it when he first got in the
league
I saw the story where Clinton Portis
said that some of the Redskins would
drink some Hennessy before they played
in a game Wow
so judging by your reaction that's not a
common thing for players to do a shot or
drink before a game yeah no no I didn't
see any players do that I don't think
that's even have you ever heard anybody
doing it's not it's not good for the
body no I haven't heard I remember
seeing the special of Maurice Clarett
and he said that when he was playing he
would say I gotta have my goose gotta
have my goose and they were bringing a
water bottle full of Grey Goose Grey
Goose in a Gatorade with his name on the
store they knew it was just his but this
is when he was going through a ton of
things but players that I play with I
couldn't think back and say that guy was
tipsy at practice now thinking back
could I look at a guy and say maybe he
smokes yeah yeah you can always kind of
tell a guy who's high versus a guy was
drunk but you can't be drunk and play
football can you be high I believe so
yeah there's a lot of functional guys
that are I'm pretty sure somebody's high
there's you know with all the medical
advances in how people are looking at
cannabis now you know social I though
listen you know there's you look at Josh
Gordon Josh scores hit that he was high
or a long part of his collegiate career
and when I was in in Cleveland I don't
know if he was hired not he would have
to ask him but I remember one practice
it felt like I'm telling like Cleveland
Brown stories but I was at the practice
he was dominating yeah I'm talking about
dominating and I grabbed him I said
listen I seen Randy Moss
I played next to him I was robbing to
this batter I seen Calvin Johnson I seen
these guys at the top of their career
you got there like you got the juice bro
and he's looking at me like yeah and
they you know I just I gotta get back in
shape I'm like what do you mean
dominating practice he said ah you know
I can lose a little little bit of weight
and I'm thinking okay you know if you're
telling yourself you're out of shape you
probably lose 5 pounds like what do you
mean Louise I
about 20 pounds 20 pounds overweight so
I'm thinking myself you're out here
dominating practice and you're walking
around with two 10-pound weight vests on
essentially yeah and he lost that and
did you look at Josh now that's the guy
who's back in shape no fat extremely
focused but yeah you know I don't know
if at those times he was high but from
what I read in the interviews that he's
given lately he spent a lot of his time
under the influence of something and
still was a great athlete
corne Robinson who played in Seattle he
had a lot of issues in battles with
alcohol he was a great athlete some guys
can function you know high or drunk but
I just hope they don't because this
window of time you know in the analogy
and metaphor of football still fumble
away this opportunity and Josh don't do
it yeah and Josh almost did that he's
Nate Burleson NFL Network analyst
joining us here in the man cave I'm
trying to understand targeting yeah and
I'm trying to understand if the NFL does
have their ejection they're targeting
rule you know college football does yeah
but it feels like it's a 24-hour delayed
targeting rule with the NFL that I can
decide of George I Aloka in a college
game he's probably tossed lift they hit
on Antonio Brown but 24 hours later he
gets to say what he wants to say or his
agent does you get to review it it is
this the targeting rule without saying
it's the targeting rule I believe it is
but we need to tighten that up because I
mean there's so much confusion when it
comes to the actual rule and when you're
looking at the game and you're actually
breaking it down what happens when
defender is trying to make a tackle and
when he's trying to avoid hitting
somebody in the offensive plate or
whether out of pure athleticism and
agility he moves out the way are out of
pure fear he moves out the way or he
tries to slide to avoid the contact he
can put himself in a position to where
all of a sudden he seems as if he's
being targeted I've seen so many guys
within moments of making a decision at
10 yards you lock in on your target at
five yards you're completely committed
and then at two three yards you're going
to hit whatever you see now if I as off
as a offensive player make a move and I
move my body on my head in the way that
you're trying to avoid hitting now all
of a sudden you look like the bad guy so
we really
have to breakdown would you let
suspended Iloka no I wouldn't suspend in
them oh and I wouldn't against going
after his hell wouldn't have given him
the same suspension that I gave Gronk
thought well Gronk deserve to write but
I can't if Smith Schuster doesn't taunt
Montez birthing does he get suspended no
that was a clean football hit and people
say well I was a clean football hit no
no that was a clean but if vantes
Burfict didn't get hit on that play he
would have made the tackle so they're
saying he's defense how can bunches
Burfict be defenseless that doesn't make
sense to me when he's tracking down a
guy that I'm trying to block for and I
give him a shoulder to the middle of a
chest and he goes down but I was
listening to you Dan if he were to
leaned over and gave him a hand he would
have been good or if he'd have just
walked over him and he didn't do the
Irish turnover tyronn lue if if you sit
there and stare down at a guy yeah
everybody's gonna be shocked but you
know what I'm not that mad at that Dan
to be honest which you know and I know
walking over and I'm not I got a problem
with that I get it here's the thing guys
have walked over me and I'm just like do
I do the Kupchak I'm aiming for that
groin and I'm pushing a book off me and
I'm dealing back at him I agree with you
but as an offensive player who in that
one play I saw shades of Hines Ward I
saw shades of old-school Irish series at
like blocking we got a lot of diva guys
I played it for this position now they
don't block I like that and I like the
fact that this young fella bought into
the rivalry we love him and he does a
celebration it's cute and juju he make
fun of his name and his celebrations
before a guy to buy in and dive in on a
rivalry that he is just now tasting like
that to me means commitment now did he
go a little bit too far cool but if he
walks back in that locker room oh yeah
those doors
hey young fella I like that do you still
hold a grudge with anybody who hit you
you know it's funny we had Brian
Urlacher on come on a football and Brian
Urlacher was a guy I felt like I talked
to the most and I wasn't even on his
level that's a Hall of Fame caliber
linebacker but you know I talked a lot
of trash I did a two yard first down and
I
I was doing choreography out there and I
would do it and bump into the guys that
were around me the defender the finish
so they would like get upset and I
remember I went to catch a bubble route
and it slipped right out of my hands
and I'm just like okay alright let me
get back home and before I get to huddle
Urlacher's 8:13 with a little dance
first of all my Urlacher you're way too
big to be seeing me in like yeah yeah
but in my head I'm like what okay so
then I catch another round I shake up
the corner back and then I go out of
Bounce and I don't even go and talk to
the corner I'm running over to Urlacher
like that was really on that you okay
like I might have just bit off more than
I could chew it or like her so we had
this like rivalry back and forth and I
really felt like all the guys I hate I
hate that guy but then there was two
unique moments that happened after that
I played in Chicago I broke my leg and I
wanted to get up and walk off even
though my leg wouldn't allow me to I get
up I crumble and I try to get up again
and I hear this voice say stay down let
him help you we know you're tough and
I'm thinking like which one of my
players are saying that you know I don't
want these bears to think I'm soft and I
look up and it was Urlacher and I had to
take a breath say wow I'm letting my
competitive nature get the best of me
and then he had a passion and his family
and as we're rustling and hustling and
the tough yards within a play and I kind
of clear up I look at mine eyes and my a
you know started here about your passing
and it was two moments that were bigger
than a touchdown bigger than any cheap
shot or cheap hit or cheap thing I could
say about a guy I went from thinking I
really hate this do - it doesn't matter
once you leave these white lines like
you can be as competitive as ever
without being a jerk about thing final
30 seconds your NFC pick for the Super
Bowl will be your on the Saints yeah I'm
looking at I'm looking at how wow that
offense is moving for me to tell you
before the season that Drew Brees would
win a game without throwing the
touchdown and he wouldn't have any
interceptions and there would be two
running backs that would remind you of
something from yesteryear Camaro looking
like Marshall Faulk and Mark Ingram
looking like a mjd out there like that
that would shock you
so that talent
then the defense coming around going
from historically worse to now being one
of the top in the league that that
running back or it could win games
because you're gonna face these
high-flying deep-drawing offenses what
do you need you need guys I can control
the clock and keep their butts on the
side it travels they travel that it's
always traveling game travel weather
regardless of what the storm is outside
rain sleet snow you can always run the
rock alright final 15 seconds who is
going in from the AFC you know as much
as I don't want to say Patriots I feel
like it's it's going to be the Patriots
losing to the Steelers I do I do feel
like we haven't seen the best stee lamps
like shimmies Nate Burleson NFL Network
analyst you can see him every Monday
through Friday NFL Network's good
morning football starting at 7:00 a.m.
Eastern you always welcome back we
appreciate you stopping by Nate I'll
come back sooner or later I'm a big fan
thanks for more Dan Patrick show to the
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV or
download the Dan Patrick show app